we are here with a 2022 us junior girls
champion jennifer you jenny for you
simply pulled a miracle and uh with
three rounds to go you are two points
behind how did you feel about your
chances at that point
well i mean i knew it was theoretically
possible but like the likelihood of it
actually happening like i don't know
what the chances are i was just kind of
mad at myself throughout the tournament
because i just felt like i had a lot of
missed opportunities and i was just
playing kind of just strained chests
overall because i don't know some of the
moves i was making um but yeah i just
there i like i knew it was possible but
didn't really they could happen
and then going into the last round you
got one point behind
your faith was not in your hands how did
you approach this game
i kind of um i didn't really think too
much going to this game i don't think i
played that well to be honest um i just
uh like i knew my opponent was kind of
also not too sharp this tournament so i
was just kind of waiting for her to make
a mistake but i don't think like i play
like the best i could but i was just
like oh you know it's not really in my
hands let's just do whatever and then um
when i found out there was a play off i
was like oh i actually have a chance
here now one thing about today's game is
that we were looking on the camera and
we couldn't see you walking around the
playing hall almost at all it felt like
you were in the zone
is that how you felt as well i think in
the beginning i definitely was because
um i have that credible position out of
the opening i mean zombies just not too
good for black objectively but i just
wanted to get into a complicated
position um and i wasn't
i didn't really want to play like some
drawing like e45 line and then um so i
was for a bit and also like that game i
was a little bit um i think i was just
tired um and a little bit sleepy because
like it took a nap after just in before
the playoffs just so i think that was
probably why were you keeping an eye at
all on that game between talia
and sophie yeah i checked up like um at
some point during the rounds but um i
mean yeah because it is pretty important
to me
and then uh the playoffs started and you
win the first game but then you lose to
talia how did you deal psychologically
with that situation
i mean i was just really upset about the
way i played um i'm not i think they
both play a lot more blitz than me at
least from like online like i just don't
play blitz and then the fact that it was
like delay instead of increment it was
really tripping me up so i think i was
just too slow in the beginning um
and then i just i
completely lost like the third position
against talia um so i was not too happy
and i was like oh you know if she draws
this game it's pretty much over i mean
it is over um and then
sophie with another miraculous comeback
and then i had like another shot which
was it was just i just kind of like
pretended like none of this happened
was the bit uh surreal at that point
you're looking at that game you were
hoping but not really hoping how did you
feel uh during that game watching that
game was so stressful because i kept
seeing like i think it was at one point
so we could have won an exchange um and
i was just like oh no just like so i was
just like every time like there was a
little bit of something i was like oh we
can play this move but um
yeah so it was pretty stressful but um
i have like played playoffs kind of
before not like this format with three
people but i'm so i'm like i i think i
was like level headed now and then he
won in the blitz section the first game
then once again a huge battle with uh
talia did you feel any nerves at that
point at any point in the game or how
did you approach that
i was actually really comfortable with
that game um i messed up the opening
that was not what i was planning to play
um but i wasn't really concerned you
know i have like maybe the computer
valuations i get but i feel like it's
pretty comfortable for me to play
especially in a quick time control like
pretty natural moves and then um
i think at some point she started
hanging uh the c3 pawn was getting a
little bit weak and
um i mean i it was just very like clear
to me like oh i have some easy moves
here so i was
pretty happy with the position i got
jennifer congratulations you have a lot
of us around the world as well as your
in the united states your family any
words for them
um well i guess thank you everyone
uh this is like my last time playing
this tournament getting too old so
um i guess it's like a nice way to
finish it off
a nice way uh to say goodbye to the us
junior girls congratulations jennifer
you are the champion thank you ourselves
as well dorsa and i congratulate you as
well jennifer you you are the 2022 u.s
junior girls champion
beautiful beautifully done and she does
go that's a big ticket once again
six thousand in prize money yes
thousands of scholarships
in october for the women's championships
that's the big she'll be back and the
seniors round
four
games
round five game